[Music]
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they arrive and in the
next half hour we'll see what's making
the headlines with journalist and author
Christina Patterson and editor of the
Jewish Chronicle Jake Wallace Simons
thank you so much both of you for
joining us this evening lovely to see
you both uh let's just see what's on
some of those front pages first of all
the express goes with FIFA boss Gianna
Infantino causing outrage during a news
conference where he said the West should
not criticize qatar's hosting of the
World Cup
the star also leads with infantino's
hour-long monologue
World Cup Legend Sir Jeff Hurst tells
the England team they can do it in Qatar
and winning the tournament will be a
boost for the country that's on the
front of the mirror
the World Cup is also the lead in the
people with a headline come on you lions
the telegraph right so the conservative
party chairman Nadeem zahawi says the
party still wants to cut taxes before
the next election amid Anger from MPS
over the Autumn statement
senior government figures are planning
to put Britain on path to a Swiss style
relationship with the European Union
according to the times
The Observer reports that labor leader
sakir starmer will abolish the House of
Lords of his party wins the next
election
and the sun says Boy George threatened
to quit I'm a celebrity get me out of
here after he was refused to ride in a
golf buggy
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code that you can see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch with us
and we are joined tonight by Christina
Patterson and Jake Wallace Simons uh
lovely to see you both quite a lot to
get through tonight lots and lots of
stories in the Sunday papers the first
one that you've picked and I'll start
with you Christina uh is is what is
going on on Qatar what happened in Qatar
today with Gianni Infantino
um it's an astonishing speech isn't it
well I mean he has certainly shown
himself to behave like an Infantino I
have never seen anything like it
clearly I mean he behaved like a madman
he said that he knew what it was like he
now knew what it was like to be gay and
disabled and uh discriminated against
this is an extremely rich man who grew
up in Switzerland so I think we can
safely say that um he probably doesn't
know but Christina he has red hair and
freckles yeah I know my heart goes out
well as we saw he doesn't anymore I mean
whether he shaved it off because it was
too mortifying him to have red hair or
whether he lost it we don't know but it
was a breathtaking stuff really
breathtaking stuff I only can only
assume that this is what people do when
they have a deeply guilty conscience
because we know that FIFA is utterly
corrupt this should never ever have been
awarded to Qatar and we know that you
know there is we know that it was a
corrupt deal uh it shouldn't have gone
there not just because it's deeply
deeply
um opposed to basic human rights and
because about 6 000 workers have a
parent he died in building the various
stadia but because it was money was
exchanged that should not have been
exchanged allegedly and it looks you
know there's certainly been plenty of
evidence that seems to point in that
direction but I assume that he is saying
this stuff because he wants to make
himself feel less guilty about the
terrible decision the FIFA made and the
absolute Abomination that is this awful
country hosting a world football
tournament so I think it's disgraceful
but it's kind of funny because you see
the mental contortions he's going
through
Jake do I mean obviously there are so
many questions about why the World Cup
is being held there and the Rights and
Wrongs of it do you think that the
controversy will end when the football
finally begins
me I don't know Christina for Drake
sorry yes
absolutely no I think it's only going to
get worse I mean you know if players do
wear uh armbands that promote gay rights
for example and are clamp down upon or
find uh that will be that will produce
controversies uh there's already a
controversy Brewing uh no pun intended
over the uh that withhold withholding of
beer
um to two fans uh over the world cup
period
um and this latest speech by uh
Infantino as Christina rightley says is
not just disgraceful disgraceful it's
profoundly absurd and it represents a
sort of elite smart wokeness where you
can defend one of the world's worst
abuses of Human Rights and democracy on
the basis that the West has done some
bad things in the past and when he kept
it all by saying I feel gay I feel
disabled you know I feel like a migrant
worker and so on and so forth uh it just
begged belief really as Christina
pointed out this is a man who has grown
up in some to coin a phrase privilege uh
pretending to to associate with with the
victims of Qatar while simultaneously
giving them the benefits of uh of
hosting the World Cup I mean hypocrisy
doesn't even even cover it so I mean you
know it's kind of amusing as well and at
the same time Christine did you think
that many football fans though what does
football gets underway will care about
all of this that they will really just
care about what it's meant to be all
about and that's the sport
look I I wouldn't want to pass uh
judgmental comments on what the majority
of football fans will or won't do we we
know they like football I clearly don't
and I will be boycotting it but not for
entirely altruistic reasons um I imagine
people will get sucked into the football
but
um I think that lots of people will not
feel as comfortable doing that as they
would generally do and the Very fact
that they've had to pay fans to go over
and give them allowances which
apparently they're now cutting I mean
the whole thing just REITs of of
corruption from at every single level so
I think the whole thing's disgusting
actually I don't think we should be
going there I don't think David Beckham
should be publicizing and supporting it
he's been a paid Ambassador for it I
think the whole thing is is really
really horrible
okay let's move on to the Sunday Times
uh away from the football and its
headline is about the government
apparently believing that EU relations
are thoring there could be a
frictionless trade if we have a Swiss
style arrangement with Brussels Jake
could this work
well I mean it I I it could work it
could be done but it it would be
reopening the um the the wound of brexit
which is just beginning been beginning
to scab over in the past few uh two or
three years uh reopening the issue
reopening the pain and the debate
essentially it would be going back to
the negotiations that were concluded by
Lord frost on behalf of Boris Johnson
um and seeking to to form a closer
relationship with Brussels which will
involve taking on more EU rules and
regulations uh and some migration as
well in return for more access to the
single market so it would be a sort of
brexit light and you know this was a
debate which was put to bed some years
ago in 2020
um and the the idea of Reawakening that
monster and having its rampaged through
our country and through our Television
Studios and through our front page pages
and through our living rooms
um I think to most people is worrisome
in the extreme let's move on I think the
real point and the real problem here is
that Britain has not really decided what
sort of country wants to be post-brexit
um it should be building on the
advantages of brexit such as they are by
forming a more you know lower tax more
liberal trade
um uh uh country and instead it seems to
be you know post-pandemic falling back
towards a more socialist position and
this would be so retrogressive I think
people would be really weary of this
Christina there is a line in the piece
which says that there is the concern
that it might be seen that Britain wants
to have its cake and eat it does that
seem fair
well that was always the promise wasn't
it Boris Johnson always did have his
cake and edit and promised the country
that it could do the same not least in
relation to Ireland where he claimed
that half of a land mass could be in the
EU and half could be in the UK and there
could be no borders and there could be I
don't know dancing golden unicorns who
somehow made everything okay and
strangely enough they didn't I disagree
with Jake actually I think that there
are there are many opinion polls that
indicate that the majority of people are
now opposed to brexit
um a very large number of people think
it was a mistake and the economic
um consequences are becoming clearer and
clearer this week the governor of the
bank of England had talked about the
terrible damage it's done in the economy
and now that the entire nation is paying
for the terrible economic State we're in
which is partly caused by brexit and
partly by Liz strauss's disastrous
libertarian experiment which was meant
to be of exactly the kind that Jake was
just talking about which is a you know
low tax low tax kind of Singapore on
Thames type post-brexit model and we saw
that imploded and spooked the markets
and is also deeply unpopular with the
British people so personally obviously I
think we shouldn't have left the EU but
I'm not sure that people would be as
opposed to it as Jake is suggesting
because I think if the economic benefits
were were apparent and the economic
benefits are huge and clear of having uh
frictionless access to the biggest
Market on our doorstep then um I think
it's possible that that would be a good
way to go well I suppose talking about
taxes brings us neatly into the Sunday
Telegraph uh when nadims at Harvey is
quoted as said that he wants to cut tax
or thinks we should cut tax before the
next election Jake is that even possible
do you think
I think it is I mean it could be
um part of a of a tourist strategy uh by
which you know in the in the statement
the other day it's interesting that a
lot of the tax Rises were delayed until
you know for some months or even until
next year they wouldn't come into Force
until then I mean it could be that
having been encouraged to fear the worst
uh and and uh you know in the country as
a whole
um that you know gas prices could begin
to come down fuel prices could begin to
come down inflation could begin to come
down as well by next year and so the
necessity for those tax Rises might not
be quite as urgent then which would then
leave Richard in a good position of
having be able to surprise people
um having LED them to fear the worse by
not having to implement those tax rises
in quite the same way and create this
buoyancy which may then produce an
um or have more chance of producing an
election win so I think that's what
Nadeem zahawi seems to be referring to
is something that I've heard around
Westminster um over the last week as
well whether it's true or not who knows
but certainly it would make sense from
the point of view of the Tory the you
know Tory strategic planning to try not
to go down at the next section is head
to win it and Christina it would also uh
assuage a lot of the anger that is
currently being felt by a lot of Tory
back benches about the financial
statement
yes well I think most of us don't care
very much about the anger of the Tory
bat benches although of course as we get
more turmoil because we will there'll be
a three-line whip on the Autumn
statement going through but
um actually uh you know the idea that
this can deeply divided party will carry
on being docile for the rest of this
term is for the birds I think of course
stories like lower taxes it's strange in
that case that they have given us the
highest tax burden since the war and
given us also the biggest cost in
biggest drop in living standards since
the War I think it will take I think
we're due to get the seven seven percent
drop in the standard of living over the
next two years and it will take until
something like
2028. it has to be back to 2008 levels
that's a lost 20 years of uh of of you
know Prosperity now obviously some of
that is down to the war in Ukraine and
issues outside any government's control
but you know a fair amount of that we
have got the lowest growth in fact we're
in recession now we are doing so much
worse than most European countries we've
got the lowest growth in the G7 so you
know clearly there are other things
going on and um
the Tories you know they've messed up
the economy we've had already we've had
12 years of austerity and we're clearly
set for another two and although
um yes it would be nice to reduce taxes
because I think we're all feeling the
pensioner and we're all going to feed it
a lot more in the next two years the
public spending cuts which uh Jeremy
Hunt has lobbed into the next at term
electoral term which will probably be
under labor let's hope it's under labor
that's going to be felt very keenly okay
we're going to pause there because we
need to take a break thank you both so
much Christina and Jake for now uh but
coming up a global splits that are said
to be threatening progress to reach an
agreement at cop
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview and with me this evening
journalist and author Christina
Patterson and editor of the Jewish
Chronicle Jake Wallace assignments um
now the front of the observer's got two
stories that we're going to have a look
at the first about Kia stalma he wants
to abolish Lords he says to restore
trust in politics Jake is this a good
idea and what would what should it be
replaced with if anything at all
I think this is quite a canny idea from
kirstana at this current time when
people are very highly aware of the
returning sleaze to the Tory party uh
which happened with party gate and and
then to Fourth
um and for then kirst armor to come out
and say that he wants to abolish the
house of laws which is let's face it uh
runs on the principles of cronyism
across the board not just with the
Tories but also labor in the lib Dems as
well
um paints kirst armor as um as a changed
politician as a refreshing politician
who wishes to to coin the phrase drain
the swamp
um you know the House of Lords is ripe
for reform
um it's got you know 84 liberal Democrat
peers that's obviously a huge amount
come from 2010 and it's still there you
know skewing the political balance for
example and the way to get into it
basically is to be rich influential or
both
um which you know in the in the 21st
century is difficult to defend the
question is what you replace it with it
seems like case armor is suggesting we
should replace it with an elected upper
chamber
um that's one option it will be
complicated to have the second election
to the country if it's going to be a
general election Style on top of
Elections the lower chamber
um personally I've always favored an
appointed upper chamber on the basis of
the balance of parties
um but you know either way this is a
canny political move from kirst armor at
the moment
Christina do you think that there's a
huge amount of public support for for a
change in the way that our country has
governed because when you look back to
the one time that we were asked about
changing the political system back in
the time of the coalition government
people weren't that bothered it seemed
I think I think the mood has changed and
uh I think that Jake is absolutely right
I think it's I think it's Kenny from
kirstama but more importantly I think
it's the right thing to do which I'm
sure is why he's doing it the very fact
that uh Liz trusts after her disastrous
spell in Downing Street and the terrible
damage she has caused to our economy
which has had very very real and instant
um consequences for millions of people
the fact that she is able to put people
in the House of Lords as a kind of
little leaving present it's just
ridiculous and Boris Johnson has been
trying to stick all kinds of his mates
in the House of Lords and has already
done so and it's I think people look at
this and they think actually this just
is not you know this is not a kind of
civilized thing for a so-called
civilized country to be doing I think
some of Boris Johnson's former aides in
their 20s have actually said I don't
know I don't know why this is happening
I don't deserve to be given a peerage
the idea that you get one just for being
a kind of you know an assistant of some
kind in in a prime minister's office
irrespective of the quality of service
you've given it's just ridiculous so I
really hope that uh kierstama does go
ahead with this and does abolish it
because we do need something much
different and he's come up with an idea
of what that could be and there isn't
time to go into that now but it sounds
very sensible to me okay from home
politics to International politics and
cop uh Jake we spoke to uh one climate
Watcher this evening on Sky who was
really positive about what she thought
had been achieved at cop this year the
Observer a little bit less so saying
Global splits threatened to to fight to
combat the climate crisis we're still
waiting to see if we've got a deal has
it been much use cop
well it keeps being dogged by this issue
of reparations which the um the poorer
countries in the world are bringing up
to Target the Richer world or at least
that's how it seems superficially but
this idea of reparations doesn't
withstand um even the briefest scrutiny
the countries that are demanding
reparations include China which
currently emits 30 of the world's CO2
emissions
um as well as great slaves of Latin
America and Southeast Asia that it was
the foremost countries responsible for
deforestation as well as the OPEC
countries in the Gulf which are
obviously responsible for fossil fuels
and subsidizing those and pumping those
into the global system and so for these
countries to Ally with others and to
demand money from the cash-strapped
Richer so-called World
um I think is absurd in addition
um that the fact is that the Industrial
Revolution raised living standards in a
way that had never been seen before
across the world and at the time nobody
had any idea that it was causing climate
change at the same time so to direct
respectively demand reparations given
all of that context is very very cynical
indeed and it's this that's really
causing the um the difficulties uh which
is standing in the way of forming a
unified agreement very briefly Christina
we've only got 20 seconds but but do you
think cop has been worthwhile
but they have to do it they have we have
to do something uh if we if if cop
collapses with no agreement then we
really are in a bad way and of course
the compromises that Cobble together are
indeed compromises I agree with Jake
about China and Saudi Arabia demanding
reparations it's absolutely crazy but
there are other countries that really
need it and um you know the West
generally speaking has had the
prosperity that other countries haven't
had and we have caused some of the
damage that is affecting other countries
so I'm sure it's very far from perfect
but I hope they will come up with an
agreement because we're in big trouble
if they don't okay Christina Patterson
and Jake Ben Wallace Simons thanks very
much